let's get to hatred mail if you don't
know about hatred mail here's what
hatred mail is because the government
that is supposedly totally inept is the
same government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom alright I don't really
understand this week's hatred mail but
there's been a bit of a break from
blatant homophobia it's been sort of
subtle homophobia in recent hatred mail
and this one we're going back to full
fledged homophobia let's see if we can
understand what this hatred is talking
about
so Pakman were you sexing men in the
home decors section at Walmart before
you promoted yourself to host this
trainwreck of a straight face Joe in the
bowels of YouTube or were you receiving
electroshock therapy at street camp
hmm I've heard of Alex Jones but not
David Pakman 'don't associate with [ __ ]
like Pakman hackman is a Rachel Maddow
wanna be fake progressive Zionist scum
wait so am i a fake Zionist or a real
one it's not totally clear from this one
but anyway yeah back to the full-fledged
homophobia why is it that that is such a
focus of hatred mail I don't know a lot
of questions about that and remember
that you can use hey treat male 2 turn
hate into love by using the coupon code
hey tree at 40 hey tree at 40 is a
coupon code that'll save you 40 percent
off of your membership at david
pakman.com slash membership